russian missiles struck the ukrainian
capital kiev on sunday for the first
time in a month the country's railway
operator says one of its facilities was
hit russia claims it was targeting
western donated tanks
the attack came as president vladimir
silanski visited troops and towns in the
eastern dombass region
the ukrainian president on the move
in the region of saporitia volody
marzilanski met to talk strategy with
local leaders
from there he says he traveled to the
towns of felicitchansk and solidar close
to the current front lines in donbass
this footage was published by celensky's
office after his visit
i am proud of everybody i met everyone i
shook hands with everyone with whom i
connected with and expressed my support
we brought something for the military i
will not elaborate in detail on this and
there's something we brought from them
to you we brought you confidence
it's the second time the ukrainian
president has been seen outside of the
kiev region the trip comes after the
capital got hit for the first time in
weeks both ukraine and russia have
confirmed the attacks
russian air force's long-range missiles
destroyed t-72 tanks on the outskirts of
kiev supplied by eastern europe and
other armored vehicles located on the
premises of a car repair business
[Music]
ukraine says it was a rail facility and
invited journalists to tour the plant
partially still in flames and without
tanks
this facility is totally peaceful and
everyone can come and see
of course
if there are some conspiracies here
maybe they will use next next morning
saying that ukrainian took away
tanks from this facility but you can see
it's impossible to do
as the details of the strike on kiev
were being contested
russia's president vladimir putin warned
of new attacks if the west sends
long-range missiles to
ukraine long-range missiles are supplied
we'll make certain conclusions and use
our own means of destruction
we have enough to strike a target we
have not yet been hitting
away from the battlefield zelensky
thanked troops and handed out awards to
ukrainian fighters
aiming to boost the military spirits
i asked our correspondent matthias
bolinger if russian attacks are set to
increase because of western weapons
deliveries to ukraine
well that's how russia frames it they
are saying that they attack because of
western weapons deliveries they have
claimed that they hit
these tanks in kiev but
i think uh it's of course uh
the question of course western weapon
deliveries are a target for russia uh
that's very clear because the aim of
these attacks is to weaken ukraine's
infrastructure military infrastructure
but also civilian infrastructure russia
has hit by on
food
storages and and oil storages and
the question is would russia's
attacks decrease if the west didn't
deliver weapons and i don't think the
answer to that is very clear yeah good
question yes um tell me heavy fighting
continues in the dombass region can you
bring us up to date on that
yeah we're hearing that heavy fighting
is still underway in sierra donetsk
where the two armies are meeting each
other in the streets uh um we had heard
about some successes yesterday by the
ukrainians but it's very hard to confirm
anything except that both armies are
inside the city and we've seen heavy
attacks on other places on uh sweater
here's this is one of the
centers of the ukrainian
christian orthodoxy
where we've seen the church burning one
of a very historic church burning and
these attacks have continued today and
also only chance one of the places that
the president visited of course this
visit by the president um
uh is something that comes at a very
crucial at a very critical time for the
ukrainian army where it's under massive
attack and he took quite a risk to go
there
not only a risk but it's an important
message he's trying to get out there to
his people isn't it
of course it's a message of uh defiance
and and support and uh it is uh
of course the aim is to boost the morale
of the troops who are fighting there and
who are having huge losses
in this region
they are he has said it before that they
are losing up to 100 soldiers per day
that's a significant number for an army
and
a visit by him him taking this risk
personally is of course something um
that will have an impact on many of
these fighters dw correspondent matthias
burlinger thank you for the update
our military analyst frank ludwig joins
us from oxford
frank the uk sending its first
long-range missiles to ukraine despite
russia's threat the us is supplying a
rocket system are putin's threats of
more strikes just that threats
let's not forget ben that
the russians have already sent between
or fired between two and a half and
three thousand precision guided missiles
into ukraine over the last three months
so we can certainly expect some more of
that uh one thing i think that is worth
remembering is that we are required to
treat
for example this weekend five crew
cruise missiles into a european capital
as something that's vaguely russians
might be entitled to do but ukrainians
aren't entitled to strike back which
sadly is the reality of the situation
but to answer your question yes i think
we can um we can expect the russians to
try and cut the supplies or hamper the
supplies of western equipment
and to continue to do so
because frank what i'm getting at is um
another question i wanted to ask you
does russia have the capacity this far
into the war and considering all its
losses to increase its campaign
on the missile front i think western
analysts are pretty doubtful that russia
would want to expend too many more
missiles on the on these attacks more
widely though ben
it looks as if russia once again is
culminating in the latest phase of its
assault it has serious problems now with
manpower and and uh and i don't think
it's got the the strength or the or the
or the momentum to go much further than
it has already but
back to the missiles yes they have the
capacity to continue doing that but
they're going to be holding some back
against the eventuality of nato getting
involved and what difference will these
long-range missiles from the west make
for ukraine
it's probably important to make the
category distinction between long-range
missiles and medium-range missiles and
these missiles are getting now they're
called m31s both from the british and
the americans these systems fire the
same missiles are medium range missiles
so what they'll allow the the ukrainians
to do is to strike into the russian
logistic rear it's probably not beyond
the border i think both countries have
given or demanded undertakings that
doesn't happen so they'll allow
ukraine to strike
it deep into the russian rear into their
artillery and into their headquarters
they're very important but let's not
forget there are very few of these
missile systems so these are not long
range systems they're medium range
missiles about 80 kilometers
there are so many unverified reports
about the fighting in sverro donetsk in
donbass can you clarify the situation
there
as of this morning ukraine claimed or
elements of ukrainian intelligence
claimed that uh siberia donetsk is now
well over half
back in ukrainian hands over the weekend
have been significant i think it's fair
to say significant
counter-attacks at that tactical level
they have taken ground back and what
that tells us
is that
the russians are running out of steam
there in that part of the campaign
they are having as i said earlier
serious problems with manpower that's a
problem ukrainians yet don't have
and it's having that effect down there
so i think what we're seeing is a
culmination of the russian effort down
there in the uh certainly
and how would you say the war is going
to play out over the next weeks months
ben you did say months and i think it's
going to take months barring some
intervention or remarkable uh
black sort of event
i see the russian attacks starting to
lose lose lose puff as it were over the
next week or two they may stand on the
defensive they may even declare some
kind of success particularly if they go
further in the donbas don't think they
will
uh and then we'll be looking at
ukrainian major counter-attacking
offenses to retake land probably later
this year perhaps even this summer
so this war is not near end yet nor even
this phase
military analyst frank ledwich
thanks ben